- I'm getting a caffeine high already
and we've had two cups.
(lackadaisical music)
- Ever since I got to Hollywood
I've been a complete coffee snob.
Like I care too much about my coffee,
and like, I need my coffee.
- I'm very particular about what I like
and what I don't like.
- I drink a lot of coffee, but
I don't know how to make it.
- I used to be a barista,
way back in the day,
so coffee's kind of my thing.
(upbeat music)
- I'd say this is maybe
like a medium brew,
versus a lighter brew.
- This tastes a little oaky to me.
It does taste the way it looks
which is like darker and more like--
- I'd say more robust.
- [Man In Hat] Like full.
- It's a moist silkiness.
But still weak.
I'm not mad though.
- It's along the basic
category I would say.
But it's, it's not the most basic.
- Oh, this is Starbucks.
- I would say it cost maybe two bucks.
And I would pay two bucks.
- This is definitely $1.85,
and I'd pay two bucks for it.
- It's like $1.50.
(cash register chime)
- Haha, I knew it!
- [Man] I ain't mad.
- Wow I really am--
- I mean she does have
Starbucks right there.
(funky music)
- I can barely even smell anything at all.
- Yeah, I can barely even smell it.
- What even, is this coffee?
- Smells flat.
- It's got a buttery smell.
- I feel like the nicer coffees
have a higher, sweeter taste at the top.
And this is like, it
goes down really smooth,
and has like a little hint
of something at the top.
- I'd say it definitely tastes sour.
- I would pay $0.50 for this.
- I wouldn't pay for this.
- I'm scared to be wrong here,
cause I, I really like this coffee.
And I think I would pay $4.00 for it.
(cash register chime)
(new age music)
- Seven?!
- Oh my God, $7 for this?!
- It's worth $7.
- It's actually really good.
(rhythm and blues music)
- What are these notes?
I don't even know what, note this is.
- It feels tropical, it's got, it's got a,
I don't know, I see trees when I smell it.
- It's like a pretentious smell.
Like why are you even--
- [Man] Mmmmm.
- Smelling like this?
- I feel like I'm going to
regret this if I'm wrong,
but it tastes sophisticated.
- They must have infused
something in this.
I don't know what this is.
- I think that it costs $3.
- Yeah, I would say $5.
(cash register chime)
(rhythm and blues music)
- $5 for this coffee?!
This was, I think what this is,
this is too complex for my snobbery.
(funky music)
- There's barely any bitterness to this.
I mean, it's, I don't want anymore.
- It just smells pretty standard.
- This is like free office coffee
and I wouldn't pay for it.
- Free office coffee, and
I wouldn't pay for it.
(cash register chime)
(blues music)
- There def over-charging.
- I'd say $1 even.
- Yeah, get read of that $0.79.
(funky music)
- Starbucks to me was my favorite one,
because it kind of
included all those things
that I look for in a cup of coffee.
- The coffee commissary
one out of all of them,
like I, it got me thinking, like,
it was like, "Woah,
something happened here."
And like it, it wasn't just
like the run of the mill,
or run of the swill, if
you will coffee. (laughs)
- Okay Dr. Seuss.